>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Daniele Turello: Good
afternoon and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
I'm Dan Turello on staff
at the Kluge Center.
Ted Widmer, our Kluge Center
director is traveling this week,
so he's sorry he cannot
be with us today.
Before we begin today's
program, I want to remind you
to turn off any cell phones
or other electronic devices
that might interfere
with the presentation.
I also want to remind you that
we are filming today's program
for a presentation on our website
and on our YouTube
and iTune channels.
The Kluge Center was founded in
2000, thanks to a generous donation
from philanthropist John W Kluge.
The center's a vibrant community
of scholarship on Capitol Hill.
We bring together scholars and
researchers from around the world
to use the Library's rich
collections to interact
with lawmakers, policymakers
and the public.
We offer opportunities for
scholars at every level.
Senior scholars.
Postdoctoral.
Fellows. The mic is
fading in and out.
And PhD candidates.
We also administer and award
the Kluge Prize for achievement
in the study of humanity,
which most recently went
to philosopher Jurgen Habermas
and Charles Taylor in 2015.
Our speaker today is
Bruce Carruthers.
He was here at the Kluge Center
this past summer as the Cary
and Ann Maguire Chair in
ethics in American history.
The Maguire Chair was created to
enable a distinguished thinker
to spend a period of residence at
the Library exploring the history
of America with special attention to
the ethical dimensions of economic,
political and social policies.
We're sorry Mr Cary Maguire
couldn't be with us today.
We hold deep gratitude
to Mr Maguire,
a member of the Library's Madison
Council, for his generous donation
to endow this chair,
which has attracted some
of the best scholars
at work in the field.
And has been a treasure for
the Library and for the nation.
Today's lecture is titled
The Economy of Promises,
Trust and Credit, in America.
It's a topic that is a culmination
of years of thought and writing
for Bruce along these themes.
Dr Carruthers has been
investigating how historically,
in an economy that depends on
credit, people manage trust
and how they reduce
uncertainty and vulnerability.
Dr Carruthers is the John D
MacArthur Chair and professor
of sociology and director of the
Buffet Institute for Global Studies
at Northwestern University.
He is the author or coauthor of
five books on markets, business,
the economy, and politics.
His most recent book
is Money and Credit.
A Sociological Approach.
And examined the social
dimensions of money and credit
at the individual and
corporate levels.
A 2009 book was Bankrupt
to Global Lawmaking
in Systemic Financial Crisis.
It was coauthored with
Terence Halliday,
and it studied how global actors
have shaped corporate bankruptcy
laws around the world.
At Northwestern, his areas
of research include the historical
evolution of credit as a problem
in the sociology of trust,
regulatory arbitrage,
derivative markets, and
the regulation of credit,
in early 20th century America.
Dr Carruthers has held
visiting fellowships
at the Russell Sage Foundation,
The Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study and the Institute
for Advanced Study in Berlin.
He also received a John
Simon Guggenheim Fellowship
and received his PhD from
the University of Chicago.
So in addition to all
this [inaudible],
we can say that we've missed
Bruce's good humor and collegiality
around the Kluge Center, so we're
glad that he's back with us today.
Welcome Bruce Carruthers.
[ Applause ]
>> Bruce Carruthers: Thank you
for that kind introduction
and welcome everyone.
I know I'm supposed
to stay in one place
because the camera's right there and
there's this recording equipment,
and so I'm going to
try not to wander.
It's really going to require
some great self-discipline.
I have to admit this is a
bittersweet moment, as I'm reminded
of the wonderful experience
that I had this past summer
visiting the Kluge Center.
And I'm also reminded that
that experience is over.
So I flew in from Chicago this
morning and had to extract myself
from various administrative duties.
I'm grateful to the entire
Kluge staff but especially
to Travis Hensley, Dan Turello, Mary
Lou Recker, and Jason Steinhauer,
for making my visits so
productive and pleasurable.
My fellow visiting
scholars were a lively bunch
who always provided food for
thought and amicable companionship.
And I would like to congratulate
the new Kluge director.
I'm sure he already knows what a
special institution he now leads.
And I also want to thank
Janice Hyde who's here,
who served as interim
director during my stay.
And I also want to
acknowledge Rachel Linton,
a very smart Georgetown undergrad,
who served as my research
assistant last summer.
And thanks to you, the audience.
You probably have other interesting
things to do on a Friday afternoon,
but you've given me the gift of your
time and attention, so I'm grateful.
I promise I'll be done before the
World Series game starts [laughter].
Not that I'm interested
myself, having lived in Chicago
for a very long time, but I know
you are eager to get in front
of the television and
see what happens.
And finally I'd like to thank Cary
and Ann Maguire whose generosity
created the research chair
that supported my visit to the
Kluge Center and the visits,
of course, of all my predecessors.
I have a special place
in my heart for people
who recognize the enduring
importance of libraries as social,
cultural and intellectual
institutions.
So now let me turn to my talk.
So I'm interested in
trust and, of course,
this is one of these master
concepts that is defined variously,
and so I'm going to
give you my definition.
And it is a definition
that makes trust
to be a fairly particular
kind of thing.
That is, I'm not interested
in trust in the sense
that I trust everyone
or everyone trusts me.
It's not so generic.
It's not so ambient.
Really I'm interested in a
definition or an understanding
of trust where it makes sense to say
that person A trusts
person B to do something.
To do X. That is, and
when you do trust someone,
you proceed with the expectation
that that other individual is going
to do whatever it is X is.
And so this is an ocean of
trust that is relational.
That is, it's about relations
between two parties
and it's specific.
It's not that I trust
so-and-so, in general.
I trust them to do something
in particular, and, of course,
trust is not the same
thing as trustworthiness.
You could trust someone
who wasn't trustworthy,
in which case you've
made a terrible mistake.
So in pulling apart trust,
there's really two features
that make it complicated.
And I call these vulnerability
and uncertainty.
And vulnerability stems from the
fact that what B does is going
to have an impact on A. That is,
A cares about what B will do,
and if B does something nicely or
well, then it's going to help A
and if they don't,
it's going to hurt A.
So B's actions have an impact on A
and that's the vulnerability
feature.
But it's also the case, that
because it's all forward-looking
into the future, A doesn't
know what B is going to do.
That is, there's uncertainty.
If the world were perfectly
predictable, we wouldn't have
to worry about trust because you
would know what B is going to do.
You wouldn't have to trust them.
And, of course, with this
kind of general definition,
trust matters in politics.
It matters in the economy.
It matters in social
life, generally.
And certainly we're in the midst
of an election, where the issue
of who trusts whom is
clearly very important.
But I'm going to focus
on the economy.
So my definition of trust maps very
nicely onto the situation of credit.
So if we consider that this
party A is called the creditor
and B is the debtor.
And this activity is
called repay the money.
And the definition
applies very directly
and very simply to
the issue of credit.
And so does uncertainty
and vulnerability.
A is uncertain about whether
B will keep her promise
to repay, so you don't know.
You know, you lend the money
and you hope they will repay
but you aren't entirely sure.
And the lender is vulnerable,
depending upon the size
and the maturity of the loans.
So if you lend someone
a small amount,
it's not a huge vulnerability.
If you lend them enough to buy a
house, it's a big vulnerability.
And so forth.
And, in moving forward, given
this sort of problem of trust,
there's kind of a simple
recipe forward
and that is either
address uncertainty.
That is, gather information
to figure
out well what are they going to do?
Or manage vulnerability.
Find ways to protect yourself
from this behavior if that occurs.
So very straightforward
kind of recipe
for mitigating the trust problem.
And the real problem is that
you can't run a modern economy
without credit.
That is, this is an inescapable
problem in the modern world.
Modern economies are
built around promises.
Lots and lots of people are making
lots and lots of promises to lots
and lots of other people.
And the viability of that
really fuels the economy.
If no one trusted anyone
else, we'd all, you know,
we wouldn't even be
drinking the water
because we'd be worried
it was poisonous.
And I'm going to have a bit
of the water that Dan gave me
and I trust him, you know?
And life would be hard
if I couldn't.
So credit is pervasive and it's
a really practical problem.
That is, if you're in the
business world operating
without credit makes
your life very miserable,
but it's also a theoretical issue in
the sense that people have thought
for a long time how do
we solve this problem?
What is the nature of this problem?
How can we build institutions
that will deal with it?
So I've got a nice quote
here from Walter Bagehot,
who was a very famous 19th
century British Central Banker.
He wrote In Lombard Street.
Credit is a set of promises to pay.
Will those promises be kept?
So, in this talk and in my
project, I'm really focused on,
in the informational side,
not so much on vulnerability,
which is an important component,
but that would be another talk.
I'm really looking at how do people
gather information about borrowers
to reduce the uncertainty about
what those folks are going to do?
Will they -- how do you answer the
question will so-and-so repay the
loan I'm going to make to them?
And I'm going to focus
particularly on the invention
of credit ratings and credit scores.
And, as you'll learn, this is
something that was really invented
in the United States and now
is quite a pervasive form
of information.
These, over the time
period, the time period
that I'm examining,
grew in importance.
And they augmented and
partially displaced older forms
of information, and I'll say
a little bit more about that.
And, as [inaudible] said,
I'm just going to look
at the informational
side of the problem.
That is, the part that
deals with uncertainty.
I'm going to set aside all of
the tricks that lenders have
for reducing their vulnerability.
But just to give you a sense of what
such a trick might look
like, think about collateral.
Collateral is a way
of saying, you know,
if you don't repay me,
I'll take your house.
Or I'll take your car.
I'll repossess your car.
That's a collateralized loan and
obviously reduces the vulnerability
because it reduces the losses.
So one of the interesting
things about this is
that there is some
measure of continuity.
That is, if you think about and
look at how people have thought
about the trustworthiness of debtors
and how to manage the problem
of lending to them, there
is some folk wisdom --
and I call these durable
creditor heuristics --
that have existed for centuries.
And on the right-hand side, we have
the title page of a nice little book
that came out of the
Bank of Philadelphia
that talk about the four C's.
And, if you were a lender,
here's a nice handy mnemonic.
If you're going to wonder
whether you should lend money
to some customer, pay
attention to their character.
Their capacity.
Their capital.
And their collateral.
Nice little handy memorable phrase.
Well, going back to the early 19th
century and crossing the Atlantic.
In the London Tradesmen, which is
a sort of a business advice book,
you see a very similar
kind of mnemonic
which says here are the four
indispensable requisites
to complete success in business.
Capital. Credit.
Fair character.
And connections.
So it's a different set of
C's but you get the idea.
In particular, there's a lot
of interest in character.
What is the character, that sort
of moral fiber of the borrower?
So now I'm going to start to
tell you the story of new forms
of information that came along.
And this very stern-looking man
here is a guy named Lewis Tappan.
And he was a part -- if you've
ever been to Overland, Ohio,
there's a place called
Tappan Square.
It turns out that Lewis
Tappan was a member
of a very prominent
abolitionist family,
so he was politically active.
But he also invented and founded a
firm called the Mercantile Agency
in 1841.
And it was a firm that
solved a very simple problem,
and that was there were a bunch
of suppliers in New York City
who were shipping goods to customers
increasingly out of the region.
Not just in the boroughs of New
York but up the Hudson, excuse me,
and into the Midwest
and places like that.
And they were being asked
to extend credit to people
who were complete strangers to them.
They had no information about
these individuals, these businesses
that wanted to buy from them.
They had maximum uncertainty.
And so Tappan basically
founded a firm
to say I will provide information
to these New York City wholesalers
and suppliers so that they
can address this issue
of uncertainty and reduce it.
And so this is the invention
of a kind of a commodified form
of information processing
and gathering
or gathering and processing.
The information came from a network
of correspondents and
branch offices.
So this guy Tappan cultivated a
network all over the United States
that would gather information
and funnel it
to the headquarters
in New York City.
And they would process
that information
and would sell it to
their subscribers.
And they would sell it as credit
reports and credit ratings.
And if you've paid attention to the
global financial crisis of 2008,
you may have heard
of the issuer-pays
business model for ratings.
This was the user-pays business
model, which is to say the person
who was paying for this information
was the individual who was going
to use it to make a credit decision.
Either to lend money to someone
or not, depending upon the rating
that was supplied by
Lewis Tappan and his firm.
So here's a page from the New
York Daily Tribune from 1844,
shortly after he's set up
his firm and is running.
And he's based -- you know,
this is just shear
advertising, you know, marketing.
You know, the modern equivalent
would show up, if you go to Google,
you know, an ad would pop up.
But in the old days you would
publish it in a newspaper.
But there's -- I've got
the big arrow there,
and I don't know whether
you can read it.
He's basically telling his customers
here is the proof of the pudding.
Here's why you should subscribe to
my business, pay for my information.
He says, no better way has been
thought of this then for such
to bring a list of the
bad debts they have made,
since the establishment
of the agency in 1841,
and ascertain how the debtor
stood on the books of the agency
when the goods were sold to them.
He's basically saying bring your
bad debts to me, all the people
that have defaulted,
and look in my books.
And I will show you
that the information
that I possess would have allowed
you to anticipate those bad debts.
If you have come to me then,
you would have saved
yourself all this grief.
That's the kind of test he's
putting to his would-be customers.
So here's a kind of a
stylized network diagram
of how this business worked.
So, in the middle, we've got
the New York City head office,
and they are still in
that area of the country.
They had a growing network of branch
offices, and the branch offices were
in places like Chicago or
Peoria or San Francisco,
and eventually they went overseas.
And they gathered, the branch
offices gathered information
from the firms that were
being rated themselves.
So they would send out
people to, you know,
to solicit information
from a business.
They relied on key informants.
That is, there were people
who knew what was going
on in a particular town.
And they also had a kind
of generalized sentiment
that they called the
trade, which was sort
of like what does the market
think of your particular firm?
Right? So all of those three
sources would funnel information
to branch offices,
and they would pass it
on to the headquarters
in New York City.
They also had a network
of direct correspondents.
That is, people who
supplied information courtesy
of the US Postal system
directly to the head office.
Then they would compile all that
information and turn it really
into two products that
they would sell
to their customers
who are at the bottom.
They sold reference books,
and I will show you
what those looked like,
and they also sold
commissioned reports.
That is, somebody could
commission a report specifically
about a particular business.
But I'm going to focus
mostly on the reference books
because they were the most important
of the informational products.
So this is a couple of manuscript
pages that give you a sense
of what this information
looked like.
On the far right, we've got
the Mercantile Agency RG Dun.
That's the precursor
of Dun & Bradstreet,
which you may have heard of.
And in this case, they've
written a letter to a firm
and said tell us about
your business.
And the person who receives
that letter presumably would have
submitted some sort of report
to Dun & Bradstreet
or Dun, excuse me.
And they would have
taken that and coded it
in a particular kind of way.
And on the left-hand side is
a page of one of the ledgers,
the sort of core proprietary
information that they gathered.
And what's fun about it
and let's see if I can --
yeah, I can get this
laser thing going.
They liked, as correspondents,
local attorneys because an attorney
in a small town knew
everyone's business, literally.
Because if you ran a small
business, you would need someone
to write contracts,
to collect debts.
You know, there'd be
some low-end legal work.
And so local attorneys knew a lot.
They were a fabulous
source of information.
And you can't see this --
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Now I come back into the camera.
I have just indicated for the
camera's benefit a part in the page
where they identify a local attorney
and this is Sangamon
County, which is in Illinois.
And there's a fellow named Abraham
Lincoln who eventually moved closer
to where we are today
and did something.
I can't remember what.
But he was when Honest
Abe early on his career.
He was a local attorney,
and he provided information
to the Mercantile Agency.
It would go to the head office, and
the head office looked like this.
They look like business
offices, with lots of clerks
and filing cabinets
and people running
around processing information.
Remember, this is the 19th
century equivalent of big data.
They are gathering information
on a scale that's unprecedented,
and they are processing it and
collating it and preserving it.
And then they're selling it again.
So they're commodifying it.
And it happens in offices like this.
The big difference
you'll note between '76
and '83 is overhead lighting.
It helps when you're in
an office to have lights.
Right? And yeah, you can see that.
Here's a branch office in
Saint Paul, Minnesota, 1895.
One of the things that's
characteristic
of the Mercantile Agency in
all of these is they were
on the cutting edge of information
technology 19th century style.
In the 19th century, IT meant
filing cabinets and typewriters
and secretaries and stuff like that
and you can see they're amply
provisioned with all of that.
So this is sort of the site of
the work that is being done.
It's informational work.
So they receive a bunch
of information
from these multiple sources.
They come in in the form of letters,
and the letters are
transcribed into a ledger.
And this is a page from one of the
ledgers, and this is for businesses
that are in Bristol
County in Massachusetts.
The original letters are
destroyed, partly in order
to protect the confidentiality
of the information sources.
So they didn't want people to know
who their correspondents were.
That always was going
to be a secret thing.
So to accommodate that,
they destroyed the letters,
and they would record the content
of the information
in ledgers like this.
To give you a closer look, again,
this is going back to Boston.
It's RG Dun.
It's beautiful penmanship.
You know, you kind of can appreciate
the decline of penmanship in America
by looking at these documents.
But they're still kind
of hard to read.
And so what I've done is
transcribed a couple of entries,
just to give you a sense
of what did they know.
When they were busy trying to
ascertain the trustworthiness
of a would-be debtor
or a small business,
what did they actually want to know?
Well here is a couple of examples.
So this is the entry
for a dry goods firm
where the proprietor's
name is Nathan Tiffany.
And his address is 771
West Madison Street.
And, if you know Chicago,
that's actually quite,
you know, just west of the loop.
And I've highlighted in
red a couple of things,
just to call your attention
to some of the detail here.
The first entry is
from October 13, 1873.
So when somebody kind of
came on their radar screen,
they would receive
information from time to time,
and they would update it.
And every update involved
another entry.
So, in October of 1873, they note
that Nathan Tiffany has made
the following statement.
And what this means is they
have gone to Nathan Tiffany,
and they've gathered
information directly from him,
and he has been cooperative.
He has made a statement.
Sometimes they would go to somebody
and that individual would refuse
to provide any information,
and they would note that fact.
So-and-so refused to
provide a statement.
And, of course, the thought
there is what are they hiding?
Why aren't they telling
us what's going on?
But here Nathan Tiffany
has provided a statement.
He said he was in business
for about four months.
He used to be a clerk for
Field Leiter & Company
and if you know Chicago, you'll
know that Marshall Field's used
to be a very big department
and in the 1870s,
it was called Field Leiter.
So here's a guy who's in the dry
goods business whose personal career
links him to one of the
prominent local firms.
That's a good sign.
That means he may know
what he's doing.
He has stock of about
$1,800 to $2,000 worth.
That's the 18c and this [inaudible]
interesting mixture of Roman
and Arabic numerals here.
So he has stock worth
slightly less than $2,000.
And he has liabilities
worth around $300,
so it's kind of an informal
balance sheet for the firm.
Assets and liabilities.
He owns real estate, city lots
in his own name, that are worth
about $1,500 and free
of encumbrance.
So this is real estate
that isn't mortgaged.
And then they talked
about some of the property
that the wife has, and
then we go to 1874.
It turns out he owns
a lot in Hyde Park.
Of course, where University
of Chicago is.
And then we go to 1877 at the bottom
-- I'm skipping over some detail --
and let's stick with the red.
And here is another kind of
telling bit of information.
He is an honest, industrious
Englishman.
Close and conservative
in his business
and not likely to go
beyond his depth.
His statement is thought to
be substantially correct,
and he is considered a good
risk for small lines of credit.
So this guy gets a good rating.
Right? And he's given a statement,
and they have observed to themselves
that they believed his statement.
Very frequently they don't
believe somebody's statement
because they're not idiots.
They know that sometimes somebody
will issue a statement that's
manifestly an exaggeration.
So they're skeptical about
the information they receive,
but they've drawn their
own conclusions.
And they do this sort of
outrageous national stereotyping.
So here's the honest,
industrious Englishman.
Thank goodness for honest,
industrious Englishmen.
So again, here's another entry, and
I'll go over this one more quickly.
And this is from Peoria, Illinois,
downstate on a guy named
John Markgroff in 1871.
Again, they talked about his
assets and his liabilities.
He has $1,000 to $1,200 dollars
in stock, owns no other property,
has not a desirable
business location
and not much is known of him here.
So there's a little bit of a
cloud of a mystery over this guy,
and he doesn't seem to
be in a great location.
Then we go to 1873.
They say not much means.
Honest and considered good
for any bills he may contract.
Is worth about $4,000.
So between 1871 and 1873, it seems
that his situation has improved.
And then in 1875, we go back to the
outrageous national stereotyping.
He's a good careful German.
Right? So this is one of the things
that you do see in the records,
is this kind of national
stereotyping
and it really is a shorthand way of
talking about somebody's character.
Where do they come from?
What kind of a person are they?
And on it goes.
That is not -- I should flip back --
this is the proprietary information
that they did not share
with their customers.
It's what they accumulated.
It was their sort of knowledge
base, but what they sold
to their customers was
stuff that looked like this.
A published reference book.
It looks like a phone directory,
even though this is
before there are phones.
But to blow it up.
What you have is an
alphabetical listing of firms
by the name of the proprietor.
So we've got James Farrell who
it turns out is an undertaker,
not someone you want to meet.
And then there's a score, E2.
And so if you wanted to, you know,
sell coffins to James Farrell,
for example, and you wanted
to know if he's going to pay.
If he's good on the coffins.
Then you would look him up,
you know, as a subscriber.
You'd look at the entry
and you'd go E2.
Oh yeah, okay, what does that mean?
And there would be a key, and
that's the stuff on the right.
Let me disappear off camera
[inaudible] would basically
interpret for the user the
meaning of these categories.
The summary ordered categories.
So the rating process that was
happening inside these firms
translated ledger information
into an ordinal category system,
which they then made available
to their customers and sold
in these giant reference books.
What is interesting is that behind
that transformational process,
taking this very narrational
qualitative information
and turning it into a score or
a rating, there was no method,
algorithm, protocol, or procedure.
It was an entire opaque mystery.
They sold these ratings
to their clients.
And you know when somebody
subscribed to a reference book.
They got these keys to kind
of tell them what that meant.
And so, in the particular example
that's probably a little too fine
grained for you to see,
at the top is double A.
And that means the
pecuniary strength
of the firm is rated
over a million dollars.
That's a big firm.
And so, if you looked up some firm
and it had double A attached to it,
you probably would conclude yeah,
I can lend money to that person.
They're going to be good
for it because double A,
it's like triple A with bonds today.
It's the highest, most credit-worthy
category you can imagine.
And these things got published.
They were, you know,
constantly being updated.
Originally they were published
annually and then twice
and then four times a year.
And the wonderful thing
about this method is
that it was very scaleable.
That is, you could take this and
apply it to a small community
or to a small part of the country.
But you could also blow it up and
just keep on adding new communities,
gathering more information,
and gradually building an ever-more
encompassing network of information
that basically captured everyone.
So here are two -- this little chart
gives you two pieces of information
about the growth of
the Mercantile Agency.
One on the -- let's see -- it's the
little red purple, I think it looks
like on the left-hand
scale, gives you the number
of firms that were being rated.
And when they started to do rating
books at the end of the 1850s,
they rated about 20,000 firms.
So that's, you know, in this
ink and paper kind of method.
But by the end of the 19th century,
they're well into the millions.
Okay? So it's a giant scale.
They're providing more
information about businesses
than anyone else in
the United States.
And then their firm itself
grew, and I used the number
of branch offices to track that.
They start, of course, with one
office when they're founded in 1841.
And that's the right-hand scale.
And there are a couple of
periods where they plateau.
That is, they don't expand much.
The Civil War is one.
The recession of the
1890s is another.
But basically they
grow phenomenally.
So this is a wildly
successful business.
Providing information
about the trustworthiness
of others is a great way to
make a buck in the 19th century.
Because there was such demand for
information that creditors can use
to resolve this problem
of uncertainty.
And it's not a national story.
They go overseas.
And so this, in 1916, is
from one of their documents
that gives the branch
offices that are abroad.
They go into Canada.
They go to Europe.
They go to Australia.
Latin, you know, South America.
They're all over the place.
And just to give you a sense --
you know, in 1916, let's see.
Perth, Australia, you
know, in Western Australia.
In 1916, there wasn't a
lot going on in Perth.
Right? But whatever was going on
in Perth, you would know about it,
if you were a subscriber
to Dun's Mercantile Agency.
That's how panoptic and
encompassing the scope was.
So the information, as
I said, is gathered,
and it's kept in these
proprietary ledgers,
but then it gets turned
into a score.
And the key evolves over time,
but one thing that doesn't
change is the fact that the key,
or the information that
gets sold to the customer,
is always cast as a
ordered category.
It's always a matter
of classifying a firm.
And so the first category system,
the first ordinal category system
from 1859, has at the top A number
one, then number one, then one
and a half, two, and so forth.
So you can see the order.
And the meaning of A
number one is the following.
Of longstanding, good antecedents.
Business comparatively
devoid of hazard.
Ample means in and large
wealth out of business.
Credit unlimited.
So that's as good as you
were going to get in 1859.
That was just a way of saying
throw money at this borrower
because they're going to be fine.
And then, of course, you
work your way down the scale.
And, in the early 1850,
excuse me, late 1850s --
and here's something from
the Banker's magazine.
It's clear that the larger business
community recognized the value here.
So it wasn't just that they
were promoting themselves
and saying this is
great information.
There were authorities like
bankers who also weighed in.
And said, for example, the
valuable services it --
the Mercantile Agency -- has
rendered to the domestic trade
of the country as a check upon
our credit system are acknowledged
by the mercantile community.
So this is basically a way
of recognizing the fact
that this stuff seemed
to really work for those
who used it, this information.
So one of the interesting
things that happens
over time is the evolution
of the category system.
So the first one from 1859.
Now we have a two-dimensional
category system,
where we've got A plus on top
and then A, B, C, you know,
all the way down to L. And
then on the right-hand column,
you've got A1, and this use
of alphanumeric labels
underscores the fact
that these are ordered categories.
Here we've got more
ordered categories
from the Mercantile
Agency in British Columbia
at the end of the 19th century.
And another congratulatory
headline from the Chicago Tribune.
The headline says it all.
The Mercantile Agencies, They Have
Grown Indispensable to Business.
So this is a thing that really
took off and really locked
in to the American
business community.
And one of the interesting
things about it is that,
although in its origins
it really dealt
with short-term unsecured
trade credit,
it gained such a powerful hold over
the ways in which people started
to think about credit
and credit worthiness.
That it was very natural for
John Moody, when he started
to rate railway bonds in 1909,
that he would adopt essentially
the same kind of system.
So when we get into long-term
bonds, which, as you know,
is a very different kind of
credit problem, you know,
for capital intensive businesses.
Like the railroads or for sovereigns
or for any of this other big stuff.
It was natural to use
the ordered categories.
So here we've got John
Moody who started
to rate railway bonds in 1909.
And I don't happen to have the slide
of the 1909 ordinal categories.
But, in 1912, it's the same setup.
And you can see at the top
is triple A and then double A
and then A. Very much
like a modern bond rating.
So Moody basically
said this great system
for assessing short-term unsecured
trade credit and the trustworthiness
of borrowers in that world,
I'm simply going to apply
to long-term corporate debt,
starting with the railroads.
And it worked.
He succeeded just as well
as the predecessors had.
And we can move forward in time.
And here's Standard & Poor's
and other bond-rating agency
from the late 1940s, and again,
you see the same old
ordinal category system.
So this way of thinking
about trustworthiness
as somehow involving categorization
into an ordered category
system really gets locked in
and is reproduced going forward.
Even as, of course, the world
of business is changing,
this system does not.
And so we have Dun &
Bradstreet categories from 1960
and ratings are breaking
out all over,
so you could find a rating book
for a particular firm or excuse me,
for a particular location.
In this case, Cleveland.
And this is -- I just note --
is around the same time that
the Cubs last won the World
Series [laughter].
Isn't that interesting?
How did that get in there?
Anyway, so this kind of thing
is going on all the time.
If you wanted to sell goods to an
individual in Cleveland in 1909,
you would be a subscriber
to a volume such as this.
And you would look
up the person's name.
And this is for individuals
now, not for businesses.
And you'd look them up and they
might be given an A rating,
in which case they'd
be a good customer,
or they might be given an F
rating, which means not so good.
And so forth.
There were ratings that
were attached to industries.
And so here's the seafood
industry in 1913.
Same story.
This, as an idiom for
examining or for gathering
and portraying information
about trustworthiness
becomes very widespread.
So one of the big issues,
one of the big mysteries
to this project is how
useful were these ratings?
They obviously succeeded, in the
sense that the business of creating
and selling ratings spread.
But did they actually -- what did
they actually do for the users?
And here, the credit raters
themselves made very strong --
but I would say ambiguous
claims -- about their ratings.
Which is to say they would insist
that their customers will do very
well to pay for the information
that they were going to sell.
But they were a little canny about
saying, by the way, you'll be able
to predict who's going
to fail and who not,
if you subscribe to our information.
They kind of fudged and hedged
when it came to that kind of stuff.
So one -- in another
stage of my project,
what I did was gather a data set
of 247 Chicago dry
goods firms from 1879.
And what I've done is --
and I picked dry goods firms because
these were sort of the predecessors
of the modern department store,
and they were very heavily
embedded in credit networks.
That is, they obtained
credit from their suppliers.
They extended credit
to their customers.
And so they -- for them, in
particular, good management
of credit was absolutely
critical to their success.
And, of course, Chicago in
the 1870s is a booming place,
with lots of business.
And so the population of dry
goods firms is expanding.
There're new funds being added.
There's old ones going
bankrupt and so forth.
And what I did in this project was
to link that proprietary information
that you've seen that was contained
in the ledgers to the
published rating.
And then to see does
that predict failure
or distress of the rated firm?
That is, could you use the rating
to predict who's going
to fail and who not?
Who would be a good risk?
And who not?
And there are multiple rating
agencies working at this time.
There's Dun.
There's Bradstreet.
And then there's another one,
McKillop-Sprague [phonetic].
And they're all rating two different
dimensions of each business.
One dimension called
pecuniary strength
and another one called
general credit.
So this is what dry
goods firms looks like.
As I said, they sort of -- well,
maybe you can't see that too well.
They look a little bit like Ye Olde
[phonetic] Department Store, okay?
And, as I said, it's fair to
hold them up to the standard
of can they predict failure?
Because the firms themselves were
deeply interested in failure.
In fact, the rating agencies
became definitive sources
of statistics about failure.
And here's something from
Dun's Review in the 1890s,
where they've published a table
on commercial failures in 1896.
So they are obsessed with
who is going to fail?
Who has failed?
Who's going to fail?
And therefore saying that their
ratings might have something to do
with failure, if it all
works, I think is a fair test.
They became the definitive
source for failure information.
That is, in the 19th
century, if you wanted to know
like were there a lot
of failures last year?
You would turn to Dun or you
would turn to Bradstreet.
There was no independent
government agency -- pardon me --
that was keeping track
of these things.
And so what I've got here
are two panels of other media
who reproduced the Dun figures.
So on the left-hand side we've got
the Atlanta Daily Constitution,
which is written -- just a
little fluff piece, you know,
kind of general business
news on failures in 1878.
And when they want to
talk about failures,
they simply reproduce the
statistics created by RG Dun.
And on the right-hand side, we
have the Banker's magazine talking
about how you could construct
a science of failures.
So there's a real sense
that there's a way
in which analytically we can find
out what lies behind failure.
And Bradstreet's itself, which was
one of the other rating agencies,
is quite explicit about suggesting
that you could use their
ratings to predict failure.
And so they offered the
following table from the 1880s
where you are supposed
to notice that the firms
that fail are the firms
that had low ratings.
You, as the customer, were
invited to make that connection
and therefore go ahead
and say ah-ha,
I should subscribe to Bradstreet.
Because that will let me
avoid the failed firms.
Because, as a creditor,
if my customer fails,
I lose money and I don't want that.
So -- but back to my exercise.
Here is a massive correlation table,
and I'm sorry to inflict
this on you.
It's late Friday afternoon,
so this is the wakeup.
You know, see who's
still paying attention.
And really this is a part
of a correlation matrix
where I've basically taken my 247
dry goods firms and I've looked at,
for different rating agencies,
what kind of a rating they
attach to the particular firm.
Across the different rating
agencies but also over time.
And there are two features
that are worth noting,
and I've put those in the title.
Convergence and Durability.
That is, although we're not entirely
sure what they were measuring
because there was no algorithm
that said how you take this
narrational qualitative ledger
information and turn
it into a score.
There's no formula there.
Nevertheless, they
agreed among themselves.
That is, Dun, if Dun said such
and such a firm, you know,
has a high rating and
is very credit worthy.
The other rating agencies
would tend to agree.
So you see these are correlations
in the point nine and
point eight level.
That's a lot of agreement.
So lots of convergence.
People tend to agree on who does
or does not have credit worthiness.
And it's a durable feature,
which is to say a firm
that is credit worthy one year tends
to be deemed credit
worthy the next year.
So this is a durable
feature, whatever it is.
Now I'm going to try
to be gentle here.
But this is a kernel
density estimate --
let me provide a little background.
Basically, what we would love
or what the Dun & Bradstreet would
love is for their ratings to be able
to discriminate between the firms
that fail and the firms that don't.
And so what I've put on there is
the scale of pecuniary strength,
which starts at zero
and goes up to 25.
And this is the distribution of
firms that are in the sample.
Okay? So that 247 firms,
they were all given ratings
of pecuniary strength, and
I've simply drawn a chart
that shows the distribution
over that dimension.
And you can see that most of them,
they're kind of on the
left-hand side of the axis.
Which is to say a lot of
these were small businesses
that had low ratings
of pecuniary strength.
No surprise there.
But there's two lines.
One is red and one is blue.
And that is yes they failed.
That's blue.
And red. No they didn't.
And if measures of pecuniary
strength were able to tell
or detect a difference between
those firms that fail and those
that don't, those two distributions,
those lines should
not be overlapping.
And they do overlap.
It's messy.
There's noise and all
that kind of stuff.
But there is no clear way
in which the Dun rating
of pecuniary strength is
discriminating between firms
that failed and firms that
didn't, of these sample of 247.
I did the same exercise
for the other dimension
of credit worthiness
called general credit.
Same story.
There is no way in which this
information is cleanly separating
out firms by their eventual fate
as either solvent or insolvent.
So and I've got a table, if anyone
wants to hear more in the Q&A.
So the short answer to the question
of did this information work?
Is no, not much.
Didn't do a lot and
yet it succeeded.
So there was widespread agreement
that the ratings were useful.
The agencies were quite
equivocal about their accuracy,
but it all succeeded despite
their predictive deficiencies.
So people were paying for
information that it turns
out really wasn't doing
a whole lot for them.
At least in the sense of can
you predict who's going to fail?
Which customers are going, you
know, not repay their debts?
What was driving it?
Well, here what's interesting.
There's two other features
of this information
that I have noticed really
were shaping what was going
on in the 19th century.
This is a form of intellectual
property.
Right? These were for-profit
businesses that created information
and sold it to their customers.
It's a form of intellectual property
and naturally they were interested
to protect their intellectual
property.
So it turns out that a lot
of what they were doing
in the 19th century was not
in the service of accuracy
and greater scientific
measurement of credit worthiness
and tracking outcomes and
all that kind of stuff.
What they were mostly doing
was trying to prevent piracy.
They didn't want somebody
to steal their information
or to pirate their reference books.
So a lot of what they were doing,
in relation to their customers,
wasn't providing information, it
was hiding it and protecting it
because of this concern for piracy.
The other major legal
issue that taxed them was
that when you're selling information
and when people are making
decisions, consequential decisions,
on the basis of that information,
sometimes things don't
work out well.
You know? Somebody lends
money to someone who turns
out defaults on the loan.
And being good Americans,
in the 19th century,
one place where you would
seek redress is to go
to court and start suing.
And so the rating agencies
were deeply concerned
about two classes of lawsuits.
They were worried about
firms that had --
who were their clients and
who'd look at another firm
that was given a high
rating and loaned the money.
And then they hadn't repaid.
And then they basically
said to Dun you told us
that this was a great firm.
And they're bums, and
now I've lost money.
I relied on you to give
me accurate information,
so I'm going to sue you.
So there were a bunch of lawsuits
that came out of that path.
And the other one was the firms
that were being rated themselves.
Very often somebody would file
a suit and claim, in effect,
I had a great little business going
until you gave me that low rating
and now I'm ruined because
no one will lend me money.
You ruined me.
I'm going to sue you.
Right? So a lot of work was going
on for these two legal concerns
that really shaped the
nature of the business.
So what happens to these ratings
through all their wrinkles
and faults and curiosities?
Well, as I said, they
succeed wildly.
They spread throughout
the US economy.
They get adopted by other markets
that cared deeply about risk.
In particular, the banks and
the credit insurance companies.
You know, other firms whose
fate relies on their ability
to assess risk and to calibrate
it appropriately and to lend
to the credit worthy and
not to those who aren't.
They had a great appetite for this.
As I mentioned, the
categories were adopted
by John Moody to rate railway bonds.
The ratings, the bond ratings,
were used by Federal Reserve Banks
to govern access to the
discount window which,
in the early 20th century,
was the major thing
that a Federal Reserve
Bank would do for members.
Bond ratings were adopted
by various regulators,
starting in the Great Depression,
such as the Comptroller of Currency
for evaluation of bond holdings.
And so what you see is a spread in
the private use of this information
and also in the public
regulatory use of this information.
So for all of its warts, this
information gets deeply inscribed
into the basic decision-making
machinery
of our modern credit economy.
And going forward to the
end of the 20th century,
you find bond ratings are used
in the over-the-counter
derivatives market.
You know, which now --
you know when in 2008
where there were those big scary
numbers about hundreds of trillions
of dollars of value in the OTC.
You know, that OTC market
is built around ratings.
If you go deep into the contractual
machinery you find ratings are there
as well.
So here's just a couple of
slides of credit insurance.
And then how you would use
it if you were interested.
Here's going to a global
regulatory standards,
the Basel two bank
capital standards,
and you can see the risk
weights go directly off
of the ratings that are given.
Triple A to double A and you get a
zero percent risk weight and so on.
So this is just kind of
bearing out what I talked about.
This machinery that was
invented to talk about businesses
and then big businesses
and then banks.
It also was applied to individuals.
Everyone in this room, I'll
wager, has got a FICO score.
And that's something that follows
you around and your, you know,
ability to get a new
credit card and the terms
under which a credit
card would be given you,
all of this is driven
by your FICO score.
It's better to have a high
score than a low score.
But that was a way in which
household consumer credit adopted
effectively the same kind of system
that originally was invented
for small businesses.
Which is to say create
a rating system.
And then credit can go to
people who are unknown to you
who are complete strangers.
So I'm winding to the end here.
So the bottom line of, you
know, this big historical sweep,
these strange changes that have
occurred, this form of information
that seemed to take over our economy
despite its manifest deficiencies.
What's going on here?
Well one of the interesting
things for me is
to witness how soft information
is turned into hard information,
and this is a term borrowed
from financial economics.
The soft information is
what you saw in the ledgers.
You know, it was this sort
of characterological
assessment of someone.
And he just moved in and he had,
you know, has a good career going
because he learned from
the best in the trade.
And his wife has got some assets,
and he's a good Englishman.
All of that is very
soft information.
It gets turned into a hard score.
And that process of
turning soft information
in hard is being reproduced
every day.
And when your FICO score
comes out or is revised,
some algorithm is doing
exactly the same thing.
They're taking the trail of
your engagement in the economy
and they're turning
it into a number.
And they're using that number
to drive all kinds of decisions
that are very fateful for you.
So how to characterize that.
This is a shift from
idiosyncratic, equivocal,
qualitative character assessments,
which is sort of the old-fashioned
way, to this more systematic,
unequivocal quantitative
measurement of trustworthiness.
Now this may sound to you
like a good thing, you know,
because numbers are more accurate,
and numbers have this sort of all
of the baggage of science
and accuracy and so on.
But, in fact, I want to
remind you that there is a --
it's much less a happy
story of progress.
So when all of that massive
information gets boiled
down into a single rating or score,
simplification necessarily
excludes lots of information.
That is, you may think [inaudible]
there's the cloud of noise
and now we're going
to have the signal.
But, in fact, the signal
ignores a lot
of the information that's
contained in that cloud.
I got to stop waving my hands here.
And so, for example, the
relationality [phonetic] of credit.
The fact that trust is relational.
It's between two individuals.
That gets lost because the score
gets attached to the debtor
and the fact that how credit worthy
you are always really matters
in relation to whom.
You know, I, as a borrower,
am probably more credit worthy
in relation to my sister
than I am to my bank.
You know, if my bank
lends me 100 bucks.
Well, you know, I'll try to
repay them, but if my sister,
you know, lends me 100 bucks.
Well, I'm really going to
take care of my sister.
Right? Because our relation is
very strong unlike the relation
between myself and my bank.
And that fact is ignored.
That's lost in this scoring.
There's a lot of ambiguous
and conflicting information
and what you get is a very precise
well-calibrated, unambiguous score.
You are exactly double A or
triple A or whatever it is.
But, in fact, the real fact
of your life or the real fact
of the borrower is
much more ambiguous
and so why do we make
ambiguity go away?
Right? That's definitely a loss.
The information is of
variable provenance.
Some of it comes from very credible
sources and some of it from not.
You know, some of it is
really gossip and hearsay.
All of that variable provenance
gets lost in the score.
The measurement process
itself is highly reactive.
That is, when Dun sent a
staff member to a business
and said tell us about
your business.
That business would go,
oh, it's the guys from Dun.
I better tell a good story.
I better make myself look good
because what they conclude
about me is going to affect
my life going forward.
If they like me, I get a high
score, and I get lots of credit.
And if they don't.
Right? So they would try
to game the information.
And, of course, Dun was mindful
of that, so they would try
to make adjustments for
whether they were being gamed.
And so the whole thing
was very reactive.
And of course the rating
process itself was very opaque.
We see a very substantial
increase in the scale and scope
of this information system.
And one of the reasons
that we use it today is
because it has this strong affinity
with algorithmic decision-making.
And you can see that in
the early 20th century,
in the way in which
credit insurance is priced.
But the fact that you can go online
and enter your social
security number.
And someone can link
that to your FICO score,
and in 30 seconds give you a loan.
That only works because there
is a background of algorithms
and databases that can
construct a simple rule.
You know? That the algorithm
will spit out a yes or a no,
depending upon your score.
And they'll do it very
quickly at computer speed.
And it's not that there's a loan
officer at the other end of that.
It's completely outside
of human hands.
Right? So when you have quantitative
information about trustworthiness,
you can build a computer program to
make the lending decisions that used
to be made by individuals.
And that, of course, allows you
to make decisions on
a much bigger scale.
To do so much more
cheaply but not necessarily
to make better decisions.
These numbers are portable, and
they are used in different contexts.
And so now what we've started
to realize is how much FICO scores
not only govern access to credit
but also govern access
to employment.
Employers pay attention
to FICO scores.
Insurance companies pay
attention to FICO scores.
Your auto insurance may be
priced depending upon your score.
Landlords pay attention
to your FICO score.
It's hard to rent an apartment
if you have a low score
because the landlord
will say no, no, no.
I don't want you as a tenant.
Right? So your fate in
many, many different parts
of life are suddenly --
is going to get driven
by this one piece of information.
And, as I said, these
measures have been commodified.
And their legal status.
You know what sort of liabilities
and obligations are attended upon
them often drive what's going
on with that information much
more than their veracity.
It's not simply a story of good
science and getting it right.
It's much more what
are my obligations?
And what are my vulnerabilities?
And, of course, credit itself
remains a very interesting
and contentious issue.
And so I'm almost done here.
Just think very briefly about
the politics of student loans.
We know that student
debt is accumulating.
The top right-hand chart shows you
the various forms of debt going
through the financial
crisis of 2008.
And what happened in 2008 is
that home equity loans went down.
Credit card debt went down.
Auto loans went down.
Student loans kept on rising and now
the burden, the aggregate burden,
of student debt is very substantial.
And there's people that are --
there's the politics of that.
And so, in the bottom charts,
we've got some pictures
from some of the demonstrations.
I love the you are not
a loan banner there.
And education should
not be a debt sentence.
So we know that someone
has a good sense of humor,
or at least they learned
how to have puns
in college these days [laughter].
And finally it's not
just an American story.
So although in its origins
it is very much a US story.
This method is now going global.
We know that the bond rating
agencies operate globally.
So if you issue Greek
sovereign debt, you are beholden
to what Moody's and S&P think of
your, you know, credit worthiness.
But this is -- and I'm sorry
you can't really read it.
It's legible here.
This is a couple of recent news
items that are basically reporting
on the fact that the Chinese
government is building a credit
system for the people of China that
is very much like our FICO scores.
Right? So they are, you
know, as they move forward
in their socialist market
economy, they're trying
to construct a credit system
where every single individual
in China is given a score
akin to a FICO score
and that will be used
in the same way.
To govern access to credit.
But could be used like FICO scores
in lots of other contexts, as well,
and so it could be
extraordinarily fateful
for the lives of individual Chinese.
And that is it.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Bruce Carruthers: He's got
a mic there, so [inaudible].
Yep.
>> Thank you very much for
a wonderful presentation.
I learned a great deal
about the history of credit,
but I'm going to ask
a librarian question
about the sources that you used.
I know the Library probably
has all these reference books
that are done printed.
But what about the
beautiful handwriting?
And I know the [inaudible] division
has Lewis Tappan personal papers.
How much is business activity
mentioned in the Tappan papers?
>> Bruce Carruthers: So the
main source for those ledgers,
the main repository
of those ledgers.
I think there's around
1,200 of them.
They're all massive bound volumes.
It's the Harvard Business School
library, the Baker Library.
And what happened was that, at
the end of the 19th century,
Dun basically transitioned
from their old style
of keeping all their
information in ledgers to files.
You know, in file cabinets.
And I don't know who, but someone
had the great idea that instead
of throwing all those old
ledgers out or burning them,
somebody decided to
give them to a library.
And so historically-minded
economists and economic historians
and people like me have been
feasting off these things forever.
So that sadly it didn't come
to the Library of Congress.
But, as you noted, plenty
of other good stuff came
to the Library of Congress.
So I had lots to do when I
was here this past summer.
It's just that for the
core proprietary ledgers,
those are sitting in
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
>> Hi. I was wondering if you
-- if I could get your thoughts.
I don't mean to go
in this direction,
but you brought up
politics at the end.
On like the lead -- you mentioned
the lead up to the crisis.
If you thought there was any sort of
mismatch or weird dynamic going on,
whereby, you know, S&P, Moody's,
and Fitch were all basically
kind of an oligopoly, right?
Granted by the government
through [inaudible] status.
So I think it was like in
the [inaudible], you know,
where the banks were
basically paying.
So I think it also goes back to
your point about who's paying
for the rating, and then,
as you know, in [inaudible].
So if you could talk a little bit
about the issues going on there.
>> Bruce Carruthers: How many
hours do you have [laughter]?
So I'll just say a couple of things
because really you've opened
up a giant can of worms.
I did mention that the original
business model was called user-pays.
In the 1970s, the business
model changed.
So for the bond rating agencies,
they also started with a user pays.
And so, if you subscribe to Moody's,
Moody's would send
you a reference book.
And you would use that, you know,
to decide which bonds you wanted
to buy, if you were
managing a pension fund
or some sort of portfolio.
But starting in the 1970s, you
know, for a number of reasons,
one of which was the growing
use of the photocopier,
piracy really became a problem
for the bond rating agencies.
Which is to say they -- anyone
with a photocopy machine could take
their reference books and start
to make multiple copies and
share them with their friends.
And so they were losing
money on that front.
But also the failure of Penn Central
was a real shock to bond markets,
and Penn Central was a big railroad,
very blue chip, very unexpected.
And because they'd been given a
high rating and because they failed
so spectacularly, a lot of investors
basically started to wonder well,
can we really trust
any of these ratings?
And so what happened
was a lot of issuers.
That is, a lot of companies that
had issued bonds basically paid the
rating agencies to
rerate their bonds.
And the rating agencies
realized oh my gosh,
we could have an issuer-pays
business model.
And then the piracy stuff doesn't
matter as much because the person,
you know, the cash now
comes from the firm
that wants to sell the bonds.
But that, as we saw in
the lead up to 2008,
creates a real conflict of interest.
Which is to say the rating
agency, their customers,
not the person that's using the
information and who therefore would
like to have information
that was accurate.
It's the entity that is trying to
borrow money and therefore would
like as high a rating as possible.
Because if you have a high
rating, it's lower interest rates.
You borrow more money more cheaply.
There's a better market.
All that kind of stuff.
And so that conflict of interest
really reared its ugly head leading
up to 2008.
And I guess the other thing
that happened in the runup
and that really, you know,
worried people was the fact
that this is an apparatus, and
I'm going to stick with bonds
and securities like that.
This is an apparatus
that was developed
around fairly straightforward
issuers.
Corporations, municipal
governments, sovereign governments,
utilities, railroads, and so forth.
You know? But structured
finance, you know,
all that kind of big short stuff?
You know, the CDOs [phonetic],
the mortgage-backed securities.
That financial engineering
produces securities that are really,
really complicated, and there's
tranches [phonetic], and there's,
you know, modeling going on.
And basically it's so
complicated that the only people
that can really understand
what's going
on there are the mathematicians
and businesses who were hired
to create them in the first place.
Which is to say they
had a problem of how
to market a security
that is so complicated.
Unlike a GM bond, where you
kind of go like how's GM doing?
Right? But these new securities were
extremely complicated and opaque.
And one of the tricks to selling
them was to classify them as if --
you know to use the
same category system
that had been traditionally
developed
for these much more
[inaudible] securities.
So a triple A mortgage-backed
security.
The invitation to an investor was a
triple A mortgage-backed security,
well it's triple A. It's kind of
like a triple A, you know GE bond.
So all you need to know
is it's triple A. Right?
It's going to be a good investment.
So a lot of the financial
shenanigans and the complexity kind
of got masked by the use of
this very familiar label.
And that, of course,
masked an enormous amount
of heterogeneity and,
you know, bad, bad risks.
So you know, as 2008 went forward,
especially the subprime-backed
mortgage-backed securities
just plummeted.
They, a bunch of them had
been given triple A ratings,
which were obviously was
wildly inappropriate.
And, as the real estate markets
in Florida and Southern California
and Arizona caved, those things
started to experience defaults rates
that were far, many orders of
magnitude higher than you should get
with triple A. So I think
-- and you know with --
and then people realized, as
you finally put your finger on,
that this NRSRO [phonetic] status
was a kind of a special status.
It was bestowed on a
small number of firms.
And so leading up to [inaudible],
there was a very interesting
conversation
of whether this was a market
in which we should have
more competition or less.
Right? More competition means we
allow other firms to kind of join in
and compete with them
maybe to do a better a job.
But here that intuition
runs up against the fact
that with issuer-pays business
model, they're competing
for the business of the issuers.
And so, in fact, the competition
could drive them to be even laxer
and more non-rigorous
than the other way around.
Because they all want
the issuer to use them,
to hire them to rate the bonds.
And the way in which you get
the issuer to use your service
as opposed to Moody's,
if you're S&P,
is to come up with a nicer
rating, a higher rating
for the same set of securities.
Which is going to push you in
the direction of making mistakes
and being overly optimistic
and all that kind of stuff.
So I think it turned out
that the matter of, you know,
do we want more competition
in this market or less?
It actually turned out to
be a little more complicated
than people thought.
>> You have time for
one more question.
>> [Inaudible] mentioned towards the
end that this was a US origin story.
And I was wondering --
there was a -- I mean --
there's been colonial trade
and colonial trade
must have had some kind
of credit rating system
of some sort.
And so I'm wondering
what they did instead.
>> Bruce Carruthers: So I
didn't really emphasize this,
but before ratings
came along, of course,
credit pervades Colonial
and early America.
But there are no ratings.
But what you have is reliance
on very old-fashioned
social network-based.
You know, are we part
of the same community?
What's your reputation?
If I don't know who you are
directly, I know someone
who knows you, so direct ties.
Indirect ties.
You know, kind of very
much a kind of the reliance
on existing social
networks, friendship,
kinship, acquaintanceship.
You know, however they're styled.
To circulate the kind of
information about who's trustworthy.
And it turns out that does
characterize the United States
before, and it also
actually characterizes a lot
of colonial trade.
There were a few more network
businesses than the colonial trade,
so it was a small number,
you know, of major firms
who mediated trade between, you
know, England and Colonial America.
And within that, you know,
geographically dispersed
but socially compact group,
you could actually do quite a
good job circulating reputations.
And so they really
didn't need ratings.
It's when you start to deal
with a high volume of people
who are really true strangers
to you that you need to look
for a different solution.
And that, it turns out, broke out
mostly with a growing domestic trade
in the US where, you know, if you
were a New York City supplier.
The New York area, you could find
out what's going on pretty easily.
But somebody from the Midwest,
in a city like Chicago,
you have no idea what's
going on there.
You don't know any of those people.
They're all strangers to you.
And you don't have any direct
or indirect network ties
into that community, so
you're really looking
for someone to help you out.
And that's why they stepped up.
So, if you look at the
establishment of the railroads
and denser distribution
and transportation
linkages domestically.
That really opened up an
opportunity for the rating agencies.
But, you know, the
question's a good one.
I think the old-fashioned
solution of, you know,
rely on social networks, you know.
And because I know
you're a sociologist
that probably doesn't
make you too mad.
That actually works
with colonial trade
and a surprising amount
of long distance trade.
>> Daniele Turello: We hope
you'll continue the conversation
over some refreshments.
Please join me in wishing good luck
to the Cubs, I think [laughter].
And thank you to Bruce Carruthers.
>> Bruce Carruthers:
Thank you all [applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.